hello everybody and welcome to part 6 of
let's play nightmare house - we left off
with a really really well done scare man
that was great oh I cannot praise this
mod enough it is phenomenal hen Majora's
key deserves a lot of credit for this oh
loading screen going into this surgery
department I'm sure this won't be
diabolical alright oh I got darker okay
bring it on bring it on
all chapter 4 already wait take it to
chapter 3 oh is that the help yay
I'm here help me get me out of this
hospital oh you're all gonna be turned
into zombies in each other oh I bet I
just been one all right mo phones that
don't work door that doesn't open Oh
blood splatter
you are now entering the surgery
department if you require any assistance
please contact a nurse at the nearest
nursing station oh boy
whoa what's up what the hell oh hey oh
man it was no even no there wasn't even
a reason for going back there oh man but
you had a scare waiting for me all right
elevator sure this won't be terrifying
all right um okay
dark hallway oh boy yep Oh Oh woah woah
woah woah oh that is oh oh oh that is
creepy oh man oh how do they do that
it's really cool oh wow
Oh got a good address oh wow don't touch
me oh don't touch me Oh were you the
guys that we're bitch-slapping me oh no
oh this is just wrong oh this is wrong
oh oh gotta get off don't touch me oh oh
oh
two doors Oh what's right eenie meenie
miney
oh this is the wrong choice wasn't it we
would like to take a minute oh don't
don't do it don't do it
by me ah I gotta go
oh oh okay all right good one good one
oh man it is too early to start off with
this access to private rooms outpatient
invective is prohibited without proper
authorization please contact the main
desk for details and booking
arrangements okay I gotta turn off my
flashlight for a moment so I'm not
scared not scared at all get on bandaged
me up nice good wrap it up and we went
up forward someone's dying in there good
to know
Oh here too
it is Oh God god damn it
Oh what the Apple oh that is a nice
touch I didn't know that can happen
heads lotion awesome man they went
through some some really cool a
programming changes in this game it's
not often you see a Moffitt does such
in-depth changes to the core game like I
don't know if that was implemented that
you could do that before that's really
cool hey hey why are you leaving what
what hey you didn't get me did you just
drop guys off you're gonna please please
like some help I seem to be being
attacked by celestial Horrors Oh No Oh
fu Oh F that oh you know what screw you
come here come here
Oh what no you ran away that's what I
thought oh don't even miss ah oh oh
gone I win I went hardcore what's in
here
nothing hey mo something alright bring
it on oh yeah that's what I thought was
gonna happen whatever whatever
bring it all blood all over the place
not even a little scary Oh
open up that's what I thought anything
else in here I do it doesn't open and a
scare that's behind it you know what
looks good for you get the wheelchair
going up here come on get in there
I'll get it I'll bring it bring it bones
bring it bring it bring it
I'll stop being such a pansy are you
John's brother Wow Oh oh hello all right
whoa hello hey guys get ready to die
surprised you didn't knows my flashlight
I got to turn it off for a second huh
okay I'll open up whoo [ __ ] slap me
Buddha [ __ ] oh it's gone a bull crap
look up get ready walk into the spinning
blades of death
oh this backward crash hold it the hell
oh not this again nothing again nothing
ah good dick oh come on
how are you doing this to me ah [ __ ]
through this Oh F ha ah ditch alright
okay something's gonna happen
ha oh oh no not this again
oh oh no I'm not ready I'm not ready for
this Oh screw you hard
ha ha go go go go go go go go go go
somewhere someone some up some up [ __ ]
me
Oh Troy that's not target oh yeah oh
please do sacred I don't think we should
be getting too friendly with the
patients we don't even know why he's
silly oh man please
well mean besides pretty sane yeah
totally sane oh okay all right
oh thank goodness oh you're real
I've just got a giant axe oh man thank
you so much oh but maybe you all have a
chance of getting out of here or one of
these okay you're all guys don't call me
a lady not the bodacious rose do the
lady's right
Oh what oh yeah a hardcore I get a squad
why the hell would they trust me to lead
them I've got no combat experience
whatever
oh I'm obviously the most qualified well
here they're gonna die so quickly Jesus
way to find out
okay all right healthcare okay okay
you're all still with me okay all right
I'm pretty sure this squad is just to
give me a sense of confidence Claire
okay will do
oh shoot it good job guys good job hi
bad ass Oh bad ass Wow
oh sorry I shot you
whoa yeah
hah yeah out of here
oh wow wait a second me what's up cannon
fodder police over here okay all right
flare
anything in these rooms nothing okay
moving on Oh what just oh no oh no oh no
oh no spiders that looked like a spider
oh boy okay
right
okay okay oh hello
this is why they were loading me up with
bullets oh hey thank you
heads lotion of what the hell quiet
thank you bed frame thank you for
assisting on that kill all right here
more bullets need those Skellington
locked door man
man you think you got a problem I don't
even have a mask I got really cold
little trouble
Oh get out of my way yeah yeah get out
of the the command still work no they're
just following me they're making me go
first they want me to die all right
I'm gonna cut it here thank you guys so
much for watching and I will see you in
part seven of let's play nightmare house
- bye bye